all right let's go to news headlines
number one over the last several days
I've been telling you about this
apparently racially motivated hate crime
at a Macy's in Michigan watch it again
[Music]
the important update on this story is
that there is no update nothing has
happened in this case spent ten days
nothing has happened no charges the man
seen pummeling a Macy's store manager in
broad daylight in the middle of the
store on video has not been arrested has
not been charged with anything he
brutally assaulted someone on camera we
you know we see it he's the guys on the
ground begging for mercy getting
pummeled hasn't been arrested for it the
prosecutor David Lightman hears his
Twitter by the way he hasn't filed
charges he's still has not and he's
actually considering not filing charges
at all that's what he said here he is
right now well listen to this I would
say to the President and anybody else
who has an interest in this that I will
make a fair and just decision as to
charging or not charging after I have
all the information the warrant requests
only came in today the police reports
only came in today and after we reviewed
them we determined that they're not
complete yet we want more information so
I would say to mr. president give us the
time that we need and we certainly would
appreciate it if you would send more
resources in to help us because Genesee
County is not the wealth wealthy County
and our police departments work very
very hard our prosecutor's office works
very very hard but it takes time to get
these right we want to get it right so
haste makes waste and we're gonna make
sure that we do everything so it's fair
and just for all people concerned
charging or not charging he's deciding
about charging or not he is actually as
of now according to him leaving open the
possibility of not
charging a man with a crime for
pummeling another man while that man is
on the ground begging him to stop he's
saying potentially in his eyes that's
not a crime
what would make that not a crime what
information he said we're still
investigating what what information
could you possibly discover in your
investigation that would make this not a
crime what could you possibly find out
that's what I want to know what could
have happened before this that would
make what you saw on video okay in the
eyes of the law the assailants brother
by the way who filmed it and posted it
doesn't even claim that it was
self-defense
okay he doesn't even so the people
responsible for it they're not even
pretending that this was legally
justified which which of court of course
it's not self - a Macy's store manager I
very much doubt would get into a
fistfight with random customers who are
coming in the door but that isn't even
being claimed anyway the claim from the
assailants their defense is that the
manager said the n-word which he didn't
that's clearly a lie but even if he did
how would that change a single damned
thing in respect to criminal charges you
don't have the legal authority to
assault someone because they said a word
you don't like so how would that make a
difference he also says that I don't
know I don't think it's in the clip but
he says that they're looking at
different footage and they're looking at
security camera footage but
unfortunately it doesn't have audio what
do you need audio for who cares what's
being said and the prosecutor says he
needs more resources that Trump should
send him what resources do you need you
have a video of it and you have a public
confession from the assailants that they
gave to the media admitting that they
assaulted him and saying that the only
reason they did it is that he said a
word a bad word and then you have Macy's
who already investigated it and conveyed
it very easily tell you that he didn't
say the bad word but
again for the millionth time whether he
did or not is immaterial to the to the
criminal aspect of this case number two
so this is weird a few days ago Kelly
while of the daily Daily Beast not daily
wire Daily Beast published this piece
under the chaos debunked heading and
that the piece is titled local
businesses love the quote domestic
terror zone in Seattle actually and her
point was that in fact all the
businesses and the so called autonomous
owned in Seattle actually love being in
a lawless hellscape rife with
unregulated and unpunished crime and
chaos they love it that was her whole
she wrote a lengthy piece about it they
really are they can't get enough of it
you know they wake up every morning
tears of joy in their eyes
those tears you see those are of joy
because they look out their shop windows
and see a half-naked man high on heroin
spray-painting a park bench while
protesters smashed the neighbors window
and a mentally disturbed woman performs
karate with an orange peel over her face
which is a thing that actually happened
and they think to themselves I am so
glad to be here that's what Kelly while
says anyway but there's the weird part a
report today from Preston Phillips local
news anchor in Seattle says that a dozen
business owners in the chop zone are
suing their they're doing it they're
filing a class-action lawsuit against
the City of Seattle for abandoning them
and leaving them to wallow in the chaos
and filth
that's a that's a strange way to show
you love something isn't to file a
class-action lawsuit to get it to stop
hmm number three a black lives matter
activist was on with Martha McCallum on
Fox News last night a number of crazy
things were said as you can imagine but
here's just one example just want to put
up this quote from Martin Luther King
and I've heard you talk about Martin
Luther King vs. Malcolm X and you said
that he you know was an anomaly Martin
Luther King he said let us be
dissatisfied until that day when nobody
will shout white power when nobody will
shout black power but everybody will
talk about God's power and human power
do you agree with that
I love the Lord and my Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ is the most famous black
radical revolutionary in history and he
was treated just like dr. King he was
arrested on occasion and he was also
Croods crucified or assassinated this is
what happens to black activists we are
killed by the government well in and if
you need context if you read your Bible
is to say that Jesus had feet like burnt
brass and hair like wool I don't know if
you notice what our hair seems to be
more like wool and we seem to be likened
to that color than anyone else and you
know it's just a hypocrisy and white
supremacy in America and in the world
that we show us portraits of a pasty
white Jesus Jesus was not white we all
know this okay
no no that no that's a no on that one
Jesus was a middle-eastern Jew Jew
that's what he was there's no debate
over that he was Middle Eastern Jew he
wasn't white he wasn't black he wasn't
white European and he wasn't black
African he's a Middle Eastern Jew
probably looked very similar to what
Middle Eastern Jews look like today if
that matters which it doesn't as to the
Bible quote the Bible verse quoted there
that's not a Bible verse
that's just he that's that's not
actually the Bible the Gospels never
once described any of Christ's physical
features they don't say a single word
about what he looks like and there might
be a reason for that you know maybe
there's a reason for that I say that his
physical is physical appearance didn't
matter well I think the writers of the
Gospels agreed that's why they don't
describe him revelation does provide a
description you might say but it's
highly my metaphorical and it's
describing a glorified Christ returning
on Judgment Day the actual verse says
the hair on his head was white like wool
as white as snow
that's the verse that he mentioned but
he think white quote it that way did he
now I don't think that means Jesus is
white as in Caucasian but it does show
that the wool comment
about color the color of the hair that's
what it's about color of the hair
specifically is what it's referring to
and so all of that is nonsense and of
course you know the this and I've
addressed before so I'm not gonna go
into detail but this constant constant
effort by activists and leftist to make
Jesus into a into himself sort of a
political activist who was killed by the
government because they were afraid of
his political message is just completely
off-base there there is no support for
it whatsoever no support in the Bible
now there is support among New Age
scholars who have who have for decades
been trying to turn Jesus into that but
all you have to do is pick up the
Gospels and read oh he was not a
political activist at all he barely
discussed anything remotely politically
when he did you know he said give to
Caesar what is Caesar's but that was not
Jesus's message it was not one about
politics and the Roman government
couldn't care less about Jesus they
weren't they weren't worried about about
you know an itinerant preacher a tenor
Jewish preacher going around talking
about from their perspective you never
perspective be just another Jewish
preachers a lot of them going around
talking about Jewish you know theology
that they care about that made no
difference to them they killed Jesus
Pilate ordered the execution to appease
the mob he didn't care he tried to you
know he tried to exonerate Jesus said I
find no fault to him I don't see a
problem with him kill them because the
mob demanded it so again this is if
there's any lesson we can apply to the
you know the current it's it's that this
is why you don't go along with mob rule
number four Bubba Wallace has slightly
changed his tune from that embarrassing
CNN performance after the news story was
exposed as false as you may remember and
he went on CNN in what was really a
therapy session more than
an interview and was defiant and
basically doubling down on on the whole
story you know in a lot of ways although
he admitted that it wasn't a hate crime
but he was doubling down saying it was
the news and trying to still make
himself a victim anyway yesterday he
published a statement well I don't know
if he published it so much as his PR
people finally got to him and they
published this but this is what he says
no it's been an emotional few days first
off I want to say how relieved I am that
the investigation revealed that this
wasn't what we feared it was I want to
thank my team NASCAR and the FBI for
acting swiftly and treating this as a
real threat I think will gladly take a
little embarrassment over what the
alternatives could have been make no
mistake though some will try this should
not detract from the show of unity we
had on Monday and the progression the
progress we've made as a sport to be a
more welcoming environment for all okay
that's slightly less objectionable than
his than his and the spectacle on on
Monday Tuesday night but what's missing
from this an apology there's no apology
how about just I'm sorry about that
there's no accountability and he says oh
it's not what we feared it was oh you
you just feared that it was that because
that's not what you said Bubba what you
said was that this is a hate crime a
despicable act of hate that's what you
said
you didn't say I fear that it might be a
hate crime you stated with a for a fact
that it is with not only with no
skepticism but insulting anyone who was
skeptical about it so and then as far as
it shouldn't detract from the show of
unity well I'm sorry it does detract
from the show of unity because that was
a show of unity based on a lie and if we
want unity in America we're not going to
find it based on lies number five here's
a great video of a white protester
trying to explain racism to black cops
my black wife is falling
all because I can't be raised this way
no sir
and all we do like to cynically sir
president oakley love you
amazing and great stuff from that
officer at the end there from all the
officers actually but you notice how
this woman it really is a cult these
people are in a call full-on cult
she's just repeating doctrine she's like
a autonomous autonomous on a robot can't
engage
she can't it's like she can't even hear
what what's being said to her she's
saying what she's trained to say you
could almost you can almost see the
spirals in her eyes like a like a
hypnotized cartoon character right
systemically you're systemically racist
systemically systemically the hell are
you babbling but this is what people on
the Left they think that just saying the
word systemically will wins the argument
all they have to do is say oh really
systemically boom mic drop got you on
that didn't I nothing you could say in
response to that systemically she's just
she's just shouting the word
systemically out of systemically it's
systemic you have no idea what you're
saying you have no clue what you're
saying but you're saying it because it's
what you've been trained to say by the
way the officer with the black wife and
he says you know it starts by saying
okay I'm gonna go call my black wife now
tried you know obviously as a dig at the
the woman calling him a racist and she
says that doesn't prove you're not a
racist yes actually it does Reid really
does I think having a black wife very
good evidence that you're not racist
extremely good if I'd say it's almost
100% confirmation that you're not racist
yes do you know why because despite what
your what we are told by these bare
coherent activists who are shouting the
word systemically racism is not some
mysterious undefinable ambiguous thing
it's not I'll tell you what racism is
racism is this if you think that people
of another race are inferior because of
their race you're racist if you don't
you're not that's it
the end that's what racism is if if you
have any opinion outside of people of
this race are inferior because of their
race you're not racist there might you
might still be wrong you might there are
plenty of other objectionable opinions a
person can have on you know in the realm
of race or in any other realm it's not
racist though that's what racism is but
the left doesn't want us to think that
or know that because it's a pretty
clever trick they know that if they turn
racism into this impossible to
understand highly sort of academic and
scholarly concept then they become the
gatekeepers and they get to decide and
then you're no longer able to deny that
you're racist because then they can say
you only think you're not racist but you
actually are because you don't know what
racism is and that's why you constantly
have left this many times white left is
trying to lecture you about what racism
is they love doing that I'll tell you
what racism is yeah you don't know what
racism is you only think you're not
racist think about that statement think
about what a stupid statement that you
only think you're not racist guess what
if you think you're not racist you're
not because racism is all about what you
think how does it it's like you know if
I think that
you know that I don't like vanilla ice
cream then I don't like it it's this
simple Zen it's about what I think it
comes down to what you think all of
these issues are about what you think
how you feel that's what it is
so if you think you're not bigoted in a
certain area then you're not if you
think you're not racist towards a
certain group of people you're not
because it just that's what's all it and
you know something else you are the only
person who could speak to it you're the
only person who can decide whether or
not you're racist nobody else can
because no one else can see inside your
head I mean you could certainly lie
about it but in terms of who is the one
single absolute authority on your racism
or lack thereof you whether you speak
honestly on the subject or not is a
different subject but you're the only
authority not some other person not some
leftist in a surgical mask holding a
sign in a BLM rally shouting at you
they're not an authority if they don't
know a single damn thing about what you
think of what's in your head thank you
for tuning in to the daily wire one of
the fastest growing conservative media
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
like and subscribe to our youtube
channel so you don't miss out on any of
our content